an experimental treatment for multiple
sclerosis is showing promise and
stopping symptoms of the disease a new
study finds a single stem cell
transplant could stop or delay symptoms
better than some medications just over
75% of patients who took drugs over a
five-year period saw their disease get
worse less than 10% who had a transplant
saw their condition worsen well our
doctor Tara Narula is here with how the
procedure could be life-changing for
some of the 2.3 million people who have
been affected by the chronic condition
worldwide Tara this is good news good
morning very good news good morning Nora
we met two women who struggled for years
with relapsing remitting ms but current
drug treatments are expensive require
use for many years and can have serious
side effects so the women decided to
volunteer for a small clinical trial to
test a risky stem cell transplant
procedure that appears to be paying off
what do you want to go for a run -
Amanda LOI never imagined she'd be
battling the Alaska elements on her runs
instead of battling her disease Amanda
was diagnosed with relapsing remitting
ms the form that comes and goes in
sporadic episodes bringing her life to a
sudden halt both of my arms and I wasn't
really able to use them well every month
she underwent a drug infusion and took
half a dozen other medications but her
symptoms just got worse and I started
having bladder problems and my balance
was really bad requiring the cane more
often ms is an autoimmune disease where
the body attacks itself and damages
myelin the protective covering
surrounding nerve cells with that
insulation compromised the nerves
deteriorate and can cause a wide range
of symptoms including vision problems
fatigue and weakness
so Amanda traveled almost 3,000 miles to
Chicago to participate in a trial with
the hope of stopping the disease in its
tracks transplant ended up being
markedly superior in all the parameters
we looked at dr. Richard Burt led the
International trial at Northwestern
School of Medicine
you have to select the right group of
patients there's these really aggressive
ones where that are very relapsing and
inflammatory that it works extremely
well in here's how it works
a patient's own stem cells are collected
and stored during a two-week stay in the
hospital high-dose chemo is given to
wipe out the immune system then the stem
cells are infused back into the patient
to reboot the body's immune system I
knew that I couldn't just keep going the
way that that I was going I loved
Trudy Mandor field was just 23 when she
received her diagnosis she had trouble
walking and temporarily went blind in
one eye in 2013 with an infant daughter
she was ready to try the new treatment
were you scared
very more excited though than scared
there's a lot of potential side effects
any procedure will have a side effect of
death as a new mom I'm going okay well
that would be bad but I knew that I had
to give it a shot Trudy is doing well
but she still has occasional symptoms
and is off MS medications Amanda is also
off ms medications she plans to head
back to Chicago not for treatment but to
run the city's marathon in October the
transplant might not be a permanent fix
there are serious risks like infertility
infection and even death
Wow but still promising for some so who
could benefit from this type of trial so
this is still experimental and according
to dr. Burt about 75% of those who have
MS have the relapsing remitting type but
of those 75% 15% have the type that
would be eligible for this type of
treatment it's a more aggressive form
but I think the important thing to
convey is people wonder why would you
put yourself through something that's so
risky and it's not just the disease
which in and of itself is difficult to
manage all of these symptoms but it is
the fear of not knowing am I going to
wake up tomorrow not able to see not
able to feel my leg and that fear is
just it's disabling for a lot of people
and you don't want to deal with that for
the rest of their life how much does
this transplant cost so it's about a
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
but covered by insurance in this case
these patients had it covered by
insurance so yes and some
but when you look at the cost of drug
therapy it's about 60,000 to 80,000
dollars a year plus the cost of
appointments and your trips to the
infusion so it may actually be
beneficial you know when you compare and
look at the cost-benefit ratio we will
be cheering her on yeah that marathon in
October
great story yes Tara thank you